[Music]
when newly elected congressman richie
torres arrived in washington in january
his presence was already historic as the
first afro-latino openly gay man elected
to the house of representatives
but as it turned out the history making
was just getting started
you'll never take back our country with
weakness
you have to show strength we are
following breaking news at this hour
these are pro-trump supporters who have
taken to the steps
of the capitol i've never been more
overwhelmed in my life house resolution
24
impeaching donald john trump the sheer
range of issues that come before a
member of congress and the complexity of
those issues
is unlike anything i've seen for torres
the introduction was bracing
but far from the first challenge he's
faced raised in a housing project
and struggling with issues all too
common among his friends and neighbors
he's risen to represent the poorest
congressional district in the u.s
with determination in independence
i spoke to the congressman about how his
journey from poverty to the national
stage
has shaped his unique political
perspective my story is the story of the
bronx
it's a story of struggle but it's also
one of overcoming
[Music]
well congressman torres thank you so
much for doing this tell me just to
start tell me a little bit about the
beginning because it so
informs how you are doing this job
tell me about growing up because it was
not easy
i was born and raised in the bronx
i spent almost all my life in poverty
i was raised by a single mother who had
to raise three children on minimum wage
i grew up in public housing and
what i remember above all is the living
conditions
the conditions of mold and mildew and
leaks and lead
the struggle to breathe in my own home
you know as a child i was repeatedly
in the hospital for asthma largely
caused by
housing conditions like vermin and molds
and i actually grew up in a public
housing development
right across the street from trump golf
course
and while the government was investing
more than 100 million dollars
in a golf course for donald trump you
know i saw the conditions in my own home
get worse every single day and i
remember asking myself at the time what
does it say about our society that we're
willing to invest more in a golf course
than in the homes of low-income black
and brown new yorkers
it was as if i was living a tale of two
cities
and tell me about the bronx i mean what
constitutes it what makes it what it is
the bronx is the comeback county of new
york
[Music]
during the 1970s the bronx was plagued
with
disinvestment and arson
and abandonment
and the people of the bronx instead of
leaving the city
largely stood here and rebuilt and
revitalized
the bronx the bronx has its fair share
of challenges but we have
some of the most resilient people you'll
ever meet and the resilience of the
bronx
came to light powerfully during covet
19.
it's the home of essential workers who
put their lives at risk
during the peak of the pandemic so that
most of us could safely shelter in place
resilience has been a through line of
taurus's life and nowhere has that been
more apparent than his battle with
depression and anxiety
bringing those struggles to the fore has
turned him into a powerful advocate for
mental health awareness
you've been very public about your
struggles with your own mental health
and have drawn a lot of accolades for
that what convinced you that
you had this mission the experience of
coming out
as a gay man inspired me to be open and
honest
about every aspect of my life including
my struggles
with depression
i became the first openly lgbtq elected
official from the bronx
in 2013 but
several years before then i was at the
lowest point in my life
i was struggling with depression
i had dropped out of college i lost a
close friend to an opioid overdose
there were moments when i thought of
taking my own life because i felt
as if the world around me had collapsed
i felt a profound sense of failure
and as a public figure i feel a
particular sense of obligation
to be honest about my struggles with
mental illness
you know it's important for people to
know you know i would not be alive today
or not for the power of mental health
which saved my life bronx is populated
with characters and kindred spirits
committed to tackling systemic
injustices by working
in and leveraging this system if you
know this better than long-time
politician jimmy baca
who represented the borough on the new
york city council and served as a mentor
to richie torres
you know one person and if we can look
at the first clip
the jimmy vodka clip if you can hand
that to the congressman
without hurting anyone's feelings in my
profession uh
many politicians are glad handers richie
is not
richie is a strategic policy
type of wonk who thinks of how to
correct what's wrong from a legislative
point of view
from a policy point of view he was head
of the investigations committee
of the new york city council and the
last investigation which he conducted
with his staff
was finding out that the head of the new
york city police department's
human rights division engaged in racism
homophobia and anti-semitic remarks
and that person is no longer at the new
york city police department
richie pursued that richie got answers
richie took action
so richie is persistent richie knows
exactly what he's doing and when he's in
the room
there will be accountability so there's
a lot to unpack there
and i want to start with jimmy vodka
as a key figure it sounds like in your
life i mean someone who
you went to work for he identified you i
believe when you were a student
volunteer
and it really did you know sort of set
you on a path to where you are today
tell me about the beginnings of that
well with the exception of my mother uh
jimmy vodka has been
the most formative figure in my life
back in 2005 jimmy was looking for
a young student to service his district
manager for a day
so i met jimmy i spent a day with him
interacting with constituents and it was
the first time i could see myself
as a public servant i enjoyed just the
time i spent with people
listening to their problems figuring out
how to solve those problems
and after that encounter with jimmy
vodka
i set such a strong impression on him
that he eventually brought me onto his
campaign
vodka's encouragement and support led
tourists to quickly broaden his
portfolio
putting him directly in charge of
solving complex and important issues
and finding success his ambition
blossomed to stepping out on his own to
seek public office
his own seat on the city council but
there was a small problem you don't
normally associate
with aspiring politicians
in my early years in politics i
found the experience of public speaking
to be so unnerving
that i would have to drink a glass of
wine
before delivering a speech or before
knocking on someone's door
we're here to say no to creating
separate and unequal schools
over time i became much more accustomed
to it and you know it's second nature to
me
but i found the experience of speaking
in public
and the sheer amount of of retail
politicking
you know to be draining for me as an
introvert to be
anxiety-inducing and yet
you kept with it what what was it that
that made it worthwhile
i felt the weight of leadership and
responsibility on my shoulders
and that motivated me to campaign my
heart out
i'm running because i want to be part of
a city council
that gives everyday people a chance i
was one of
nine candidates when i first ran for the
city council back in 2013
and very few people thought i would win
but
i won because i knocked on thousands of
doors and people came to see their hopes
and dreams for their children
embodied in my candidacy and my story so
there are a number of people who would
be quite content and have been
more than content to serve as a city
council member
for the biggest and some would argue the
greatest city
in america maybe the world and yet you
make a decision to take it a step
further
to run for congress tell me about that
decision
i came to realize that there was a limit
to what i could do at the local level
and so i had an epiphany that if i want
to become a transformational policymaker
if i want to have a systemic impact
improving life in public housing in
breaking the cycle of racially
concentrated poverty
then i have to be in washington dc
because that's where the rules are set
and so i ran for congress and i ran in
the most fiercely contested
congressional primary in new york city i
was one
of 11 candidates the race included
the vice chair of the dnc the former
speaker of the new york city council
a candidate endorsed by bernie sanders
and the most formidable opponent was a
man by the name of reuben d
s senior who was known to be the most
anti-lgbtq
elected official in new york state
politics
and for me the triumph of an openly
lgbtq candidate
is a powerful testament to how far we've
come as a society
and i often point out who would have
thought that the first
openly lgbtq member of the new york city
congressional delegation
would come not from chelsea or the
village
or hell's kitchen but from the south
bronx
another way taurus has challenged
expectations as a councilman and a
congressman
is his willingness to engage with new
york city's business community
it's a move that in recent times carries
significantly more risk
especially for a politician embracing a
progressive agenda
he caught the attention of kathy wilde
ceo of the partnership for new york city
she represents some of the most powerful
and wealthy business interests
in new york i want to bring in one more
clip if we can
i'm afraid to listen because i know
kathy does not suffer fools
she does not but i i i'm interested to
get your reaction to this go ahead
yes i met richie early in his tenure on
the city council
2014 when he first started and
he wasn't ideological he hadn't
stereotyped
business as being the bad guys he was
really
open and interested he represents the
poorest congressional district or
certainly one of them in the country
and yet he didn't see the wealthy
the ceos as being a negative force he
was looking for them to come into his
community
help with the development of affordable
housing richie made it clear
that government does not have all the
solutions and there's hardly any
political person
around these days who sees the world
that way
so yes that's he's courageous and he's
willing to stand up and say i'm going to
be my own person
so an interesting perspective from
someone who knows the
the corridors of power for sure tell me
about
how you approach what has become a hot
button issue which is
wealth and money in this big city that
we live in
you know as a city council member i'm
willing to speak to kathy i'm willing to
speak to
the businesses that she represents in
order to understand
the industries that government are
regulating
does it mean that i'm necessarily going
to agree on every issue no
but i feel it's important to disagree
without
demonizing you know there are those who
approach
politics with the fundamentalism of a
religion
right there are those who essentially
say i alone have the absolute truth
my policy prescriptions
are the only path to salvation and
anyone who disagrees with me is not
simply wrong but evil
and should be burned at the stake for
heresy
you know from my vantage point that kind
of fundamentalism
is incompatible with the very nature of
politics
which is about compromise and coalition
building
and mutual understanding so i have to
ask you
and as we start to wrap up here about
three wednesdays
your first three wednesdays as a member
of congress
i don't even know where to begin other
than to say
what were those three wednesdays like i
refer to it as the three wildest
wednesdays
on january 6th insurrection
on january 13th impeachment
and on january 20th inauguration
this has been the most
dramatic and draining and disorienting
month
for any freshman class in the modern
history of the united states
do you solemnly swear that you will
support and defend
i suspect the freshman class that
entered congress during the civil war
had much more drama than we did
but by contemporary standards uh the
drama that we've seen in january
um is second to none
the siege on the capitol was reminiscent
of 9 11.
you know i had the same sense of shock
on january 6 that i had a 911.
[Applause]
i was in a state of shock that a violent
mob
would so willingly and could so easily
storm the capital
and invade the senate chamber and
terrorize members of congress and their
staff
you know and i have a number of
colleagues who are struggling with
post-traumatic stress
in the wake of the siege and so as you
settle in even with that as a backdrop
how are you finding it what what is it
like
covet is a challenge you know congress
is a collegial institution
you're only as strong as the
relationships you build
because the goal is to leverage those
relationships in the service of
solving problems and passing legislation
and
and covert 19 is hamstrung the ability
to build relationships
so uh it's been eventful and
do you look at the district differently
now
what how does it feel to you how does it
look to you now that you are
representing it in washington
representing these people
that you grew up among how do you think
of yourself differently i guess
uh now that you're in the seat as a
member of congress
you know i'm not simply a representative
of the south bronx i'm approaching
issues that have
implications for national security and
the international community
you know whether it's terrorism or the
solarwinds hacking of government and
corporate networks
these are issues that transcend the
provincial
concerns of a particular congressional
district and it's important for me as a
member of congress to be engaged on
those issues to understand them deeply
so that i can legislate thoughtfully but
first and foremost i am a representative
of the south bronx
you know my mother has taught me that
the most important lesson
is to never forget where you come from
never forget where your roots lie
never forget the people who voted you
into office
i want people to say you know my life is
better for having known
richie taurus if people say that then i
know mine has been a life well-lived
you